pressures mounting on Libyan general
Khalifa Haftar to stop his advance on
the capital Tripoli forces Lord the
general carried out an airstrike on
tripolis only functioning Airport on
Monday reports say the strike hit a
runway without causing casualties half
tower is trying to seize Tripoli from
the UN back government there thousands
have fled the fighting so who is general
Haftarah and why has he started this
offensive we have this report the
overthrow of Colonel Gaddafi in 2011
plunge Libya into chaos for four decades
he had ruled the country with an iron
hand holding together Libya's disparate
groups including some 140 tribes and
clans his death left a power vacuum the
government in the capital has limited
power even though it's recognized by
much of the international community it's
rivaled by a parallel government in the
eastern city of Tobruk both
administrations have Parliament's and
Armed Forces adding to the chaos various
militias are also fighting for their own
regional interests military commander
Khalifa Haftar
who's leading the current attack on
Tripoli is loyal to the administration
in Tobruk he took part in the 2011
uprising against Gaddafi and then
initially disappeared from the scene but
in 2014 he returned taking fighters to
the city of Benghazi they defeated Al
qaeda-linked militants who were
effectively controlling the city and
much of the region the operation took
nearly two years it one-half to
widespread credit in eastern Libya and
some recognition abroad - but he didn't
stop there after consolidating his hold
on the east he swept through the
oil-rich south of the country earlier
this year and now he's turned his focus
on the capital after has backing from
Russia and Egypt its supporters see him
as the best hope of unifying Libya under
one government while his opponents fear
he would be another dictator like
Colonel Gaddafi despite media reports
that Russia has
send troops to Libya Moscow has so far
denied supporting half darkness forces
in their offensive on the capital
Tripoli for more on this I'm joined by
dr. Leona si he's an expert on
international relations at the higher
School of Economics in Moscow welcome to
you now how credible are reports that
Russia has troops in Libya and what role
are they playing in this lately latest
battle for the control of Tripoli hello
good afternoon you know - now I didn't
see any proof evidence regarding the
Russian troops in Libya but I I guess we
can say about Russian first of all about
Russian instructors in Egypt and an ABA
we can talk about the strong cooperation
of Libyan issue with Egyptians and on
the Egyptian military bases and I guess
we can talk about the Russian private
military campaigns in Libya but I'm not
sure that the role of Russia or role of
Russia and the role of Russian private
military campaigns and Russian
instructors was so high if we are
talking about the this battle on on
Tripoli so I guess mostly Russia
interested in in in in in in dialogue
and in conference on Libya and in
cooperation with political party said
you're suggesting that Russia has no
boots on the ground but it is offering
military support and cooperation to
general have thought what are Russia's
strategic aims in that region you know
if you are talking about the Russia
Russian interests in the Middle East so
it's it should be clear that we haven't
got any real strategic long-term goals
in this region I guess in Libya and also
in Syria
we have to we have to to two main main
goals and and that's the first one we
would like to use Syria and Libya
of course at the barre gradient sheep
with our negotiations with the West and
it should be clear that this is our main
I guess reason in in Libya to use the
the Libyan issue in our negotiations
with with Rome and Paris and the the
second one we would like to use our
presence in the Middle East in our
relations with with the Gulf countries
so these two two reasons for a suit main
reason for us I don't believe that we
have any other strategic and long-term
interest in in the Middle East North
Africa right international analyst dr.
Leona is I've in a Moscow thank you very
much for your assessment thank you